ある日 この目連尊者と
うんと お釈迦様の二番目の弟子ですね
それから誰でしたっけ？ラッカナ長老という名前
ラッカナ長老ですね あの霊鷲山から霊鷲山にて降りてくるんです
で 目連尊者がちょっとニコッと笑ったんです
もう何もないところで
ラッカナ長老はもうなんで笑ったんでしょうかと
これは今聞くところじゃないんだよと
お釈迦様でもいるところで聞いたらどうですかと
これでその場で説明しないんですね
それで まあ夜が終わって
お釈迦様のところに集めたところで
またラッカナ長老が目連尊者にあの
あの なんで笑ったんですかと
霊鷲山で 言ったら私はある餓鬼を見ましたと目連尊者言うんです
それですね ある ある霊を見たんだと
この霊の体は 頭は人間の形取ってますよと
しかし体はずっと蛇ですと
体の形は蛇です 頭だけ人間の頭
そこで体はもうもう想像を絶するぐらい長いんだと
というか このパンチャヴィーサティ二十五余尋
二十五 余尋 余尋と日本語で見えますけどね
距離はあまり言えませんですけど
まあまあキロぐらいかな
そこまではないかもね
まあ普通の男性にいっぺんに歩ける距離です
そこでちょこっと休まなきゃいけないという距離だから
もう本当に距離は言えませんよ
で 今みたいに何キロでしょうかとかね
昔はやっぱり何でもかんでも存在で見るんですよ
だから一キロ歩くと人は疲れますよと
言っても 一キロ歩いて疲れる人もいるし
まるっきり疲れないもいるんだから
ちょっとおかしくなるんですね
だから逆に仏教なんかは人が疲れるぐらいの距離
言うと 人によってその距離が違うんです
そうすると真理語れます
そこで人がまあ疲れるぐらいの距離は余尋という名前にすれば
まあ一余尋歩けたらかなり疲れるでしょうと言ったら
子供はそうですねとか
大人もそうですねとかね
すごい体力のある軍人も
ああ そうですねとかね
納得いくんです しかし
現代的に測ってみると
その余尋がバラバラですね
子供が思う余尋と軍人が思う余尋は
これはかなり違う 年寄りが思う余尋とまた違う
しかし 事実はちゃんと通じています
一余尋走ると まあ疲れて水も飲みたくなるでしょう
体疲れますよとかいうことは説法できます
だからそこはもうまた現代思考っていうのはどうでもいいのに
現代思考はね なんで仏教は現代思考でいろんな人は解説しようとするんでしょうかと
何もね 真理発見することもないし
心育ったことでもないし
怒り憎しみでもう鈍足に陥っている西洋思考の概念で仏教は解説するっていうのはね
とにかく余尋って何距離
何キロでしょうかというふうに説明しなくちゃいけないし
私は知りませんだけど
一応誰か誰かがね これ四キロぐらいには当たりますよとかね
言ったりしてね まあどうでもいいんです
とにかく人が二十五回休みなきゃいけないぐらい長いってことなんです
だからストーリー聞く人は自分ではどれぐらいこの蛇の体が長いかと考えればいいでしょうに
とにかくものすごい長い体
それでこの人の頭から火が上がるんですよ
その火が頭から上げ上がった日が炎がずっと体でずっと伝わって尾っぽまで行くんです
その餓鬼を燃やしながら
だから長さが必要なんです
短くなっちゃうと苦しみが少ないんです
頭から炎が上がって燃えて燃えて燃えて燃えて燃えて尾っぽまで行くと
それで それで尾っぽのところも何か中で石油油田でも入ってるかわかりません
だけどその餓鬼の体の中で尾っぽの方からまた火の炎が上がっちゃうんです
上がってすーっと上に体通って頭まで行って燃えちゃう
燃やしちゃうんですね
だから燃えない瞬間ないんですね
結局は 上から炎が見ても
あちらから始めて出てくるんだから
どんな瞬間でも体燃えています
だからちょこっと時間に対して
いつでも二倍の炎で燃えている
こちらとあちらから それで十分でしょうが
体の真ん中からも日が二つは上げて
また上に行くんだと それでも二十五
四十五で百キロぐらいだから
これぐらい大きな蛇の体だから太さも結構あるでしょうに
細い糸ではないんだからね
そういうわけだから 脇からも日が上がっているんです
上がって燃やしているんだと
そういういくつかのこの餓鬼たちいたということで
まあまあこちらこのあります
まああのテキストにはありますけど
あのこちらこの蛇の餓鬼を見た時だけで
他の餓鬼のことを一緒に書くんだから
まあ面白くなくなっちゃいます
このストーリーは そこでこの目連尊者が笑ったんですけど
まあまあ時間的にちょっとわからない
とにかくその餓鬼と 霊と話すんですよ
他の人には聞こえませんだけど
一応話してみる あんたそんな形でね
こんな苦しんでいて それでも死なないし
何やった人でしょうかと
これ説明できん このストーリーはもう全部ストーリー一つに
ガキのストーリーいくつかありまして
これ全部一つにまとめているんだから
もうストーリーになりません
ま とにかくまあ お釈迦様の前でこういうガキを見たというんですね
で なんでそこでもうこういう風にややこしくするんでしょうかと
ただ単にもっとかっこいいでしょ
現代のね 日本の霊能者たちみたいに
この前テレビ見ていたんですけど
今丹波さんが今こちらにいますよとかね
それでまた二言割りあっ
今丹波さんがあんたにどけって言ってますよとかね
これ俺の場所やと言ってるんだよとかね
そういう風に言った方がもう信頼できるしね
嘘を言うならば そうやっていくらでも平気で嘘を言えますよ
あ 今こちら何々さんがもう来ているんだよとかね
それで霊能者ではなくて
よく読めてるのは一般人がいかに無知かということをよく気をつけてください
一般人っていうのは想像を絶する非論理的無知なんですよ
あのテレビで今はすごい金儲かっている
あのもうすごい霊能者がね
もう体見ただけで やっぱりこの人は相当なインチキ詐欺嘘やと
それでそれなりに能力あるんですよ
人を騙す能力すごいもんですよ
私には 私にもいろんなストーリーはいくらでも作れますけど
騙すところまで持っていかないんですね
やっぱり時々子供なら騙しちゃいますけど
すぐバレますね バレるようにします
でなきゃ嘘ついたことになりますからね
あれはあれで食べてるんだからね
だから霊能力者で霊は自分とよく喋る
天国にいたお父さんの手紙持ってくる
よくもや あそこまで言えるところはさすが能力ですけど
霊能じゃないんです とにかく
ただ あまり関係ない家族で中で父親がこんなこと言ってるんだよっていうことをそこで言えるのは
もう大した能力です それもデータは先に取ってますけどね
どんな関係 どういう形
そうするといくらかわかるでしょ
これは言いたがってるでしょとかね
例えば会社 子たち親が死んじゃったデータ取ってみたら
会社が息子の経営が悪くて潰れそうになっているし
ちょこちょこっとなんか息子は別な会社やりたいって気分もあったりするし
それぐらいわかるでしょ
現実のデータだから それでもう天界から手紙来るんで
父親で それで今あなたのそばに座ってます
お父様と ちょこっと何か感じないの？何か感じないの？言うと
本人もいえ 何も感じないという
言いにくい つらいでしょうね
そういえばちょこっと何か感じますよと
今お父さんね 本当にあなたのこと心配しているんだよと言うともう父親っていうのは生きてる間はものすごく嫌味で嫌いで
半分ばっかりやってる連中っていうのは死んじゃったらすっごく心配するんです
父親心配してるよって言ったら
やっぱり気持ちが変わるんですね
だからもうちょこっと余裕を見て
実はね もうこういう笑わなくちゃいけないんです
まあ実はね 父親ね 自分がすごく苦労して会社を発展させましたと
でも今うまくいかないことはね
父親本当にすごく残念に思ってますよ
しかし この自分会社よりはね
あなたのこと心配しているんだと
ですから今お父さんはね
あの好きな通りにやってくださいと
会社閉鎖しても大丈夫やと
自分好きなことをやって頑張ってくださいとお父さん言ってますよと
会社辞めても会社なんて言いますか
解散させても父親は気にしませんよと
息子はもう最高でしょう
気持ちは それから自分やりたいことは別にあるんだから
それやるとうまくいくに決まってるでしょうに
ただ 父親が作った会社だから
やっぱりこれ倒産しちゃまずいなとかね
もうもうご先祖様にはもうそういう気持ちうまくいくはずがないでしょうね
能力もない場合はね 自分がちっちゃい時から別なことをやりたかったんだから
お父さんに「じゃあやってください 」
もう行くのは決まっている
そうすると「さすが霊能者」って
だからそういう計算っていうのも本当にもうそれはすごいと思いますよ
だからこの言ってることはちょっと理性で見るとすぐバレるはずなんですよ
でもあの 「今来てるんだ」とか言っちゃうと信じるというところって
人間のバカバカらしさ
それはスリランカ人にだけは言わないでください
恐ろしい あの連中は 「
じゃあ証拠を出せ」と言うんで
行きます でなきゃ見てますよ
スリランカでは悪魔踊りっていう踊りがあるんですよ
この昔 この仏教入る前に原始時代からあったこの除霊ですね
除霊儀礼 しかし 踊りとして
歌として 文化として もうかなり発展して歴史古いんだから
国の文化として大事に守っていて
我々生まれる時はその習慣はもうとっくに消えてあったんです
この真面目に信じて悪魔祓いするっていうことはない
しかし やる 伝統だから
で 病気の時やることをやめちゃったんです
その代わりにこの霊が乗り移ったとかね
もう悪霊に触られたとか言って
特に女の人なんかはね
よく病気になるんです
それでこの人よく「この女は結婚適齢だからね
もうやっぱり恥ずかしくてね
男と喋れませんしね 」
って裏で言うんですね 「
もう誰かと一緒にさせちゃえば終わるもんですけど」とか
と言いながら ちゃんと真面目に一応悪霊祓いもやる
よくあることは この霊が乗り移す
移す 移すてもらうんです
患者に それで患者も踊ったり踊ったりする
で なんでこの霊が乗り移ったのか
その理由も言ってくれる
こういう こういうことで
それと祈祷師が 「じゃあここはこんな娘さんに冷めたいけませんよ」と
そんなことしたって「娘に命が欲しい」とかなんとか言うんですね 「
お前にあげるわけじゃないんだよ」と
脅したりもする で 「お前そんなことしたら地獄に落ちるでしょう」と
これはブッダを守っている人々やと
だからものは話し もう話し合いだから
君が何を期待しているのかと
で そこはなんとか考えておきますから
まあ娘を離してあげてくださいという対話やるんですね
これは普通の国 言語で
言葉でやるんだから 待っている人々にとっては満載で面白いんです
面白いこと この病気になっているこの女の人も適当に返事するんですね
その時は 声は変わってますけど
よく適当に返事はする
まあそれでいろいろ約束がもう交わして
仏教的なになってますから
この除霊はね もう追い出したりとかはないんです
話し合って それで自分がこういうこういうお供え欲しいとかね
これこれもらっちゃえばもう行きますと
言って それなりにじゃああげますから
じゃあ帰りますかと 帰りますか？と
帰りますと それでは我々は納得いきませんよと言うんです
祈祷師が 納得いきませんと
何か証拠を出せと 言うと何か証拠を言うんだそうです
そこまで私は見たのはすごい小さい時だから
ちょっと調べることはできなかったんです
小さい時もすごく性格悪かったんで
とにかく信じます 調べる
すごい小さい時 この悪霊払いとは見たことありますけど
ものすごく小さくて もう誰かと一緒に夜は行ったり来たりしなくちゃいけないし
もう怖いしね で 詳しかったんで調べることできなかったんだからね
それで朝時間がありますよ
出ていく時間が その時間になってくると
では何とかして行きます
いろいろ誰かを血が吐くようにしてあげますとかね
それで私は出て行った証拠だと
で 祈祷師が怒るんです
そんなことやったらお前釘付けて置いてやるぞと
自由に出せませんよと
別なことを証拠を出しなさいと言ったら
また何とか言ってとかね
じゃあ家にあるニワトリをね
二匹の首をひねって動物殺したらね
ただでさえまた祈祷師が怒るんです
とにかく最低は何とか大きな枝で
だいたい決まってる枝もありますけど
このジャックフルーツのね
じゃあ枝を本落としてやるぞと
それぐらいなら大丈夫やと
言うと一応規定儀式で終わると
みんな言うんですね やっぱり見事にその時間で枝一つ落ちましたよと
だから大丈夫 もう霊が出ていったと
だから私は本当にその時間で自動的に枝が落ちるのかと
もうこれもう歳時はそれできんだから
また朝大体時半ですよ
時間は 時半と時あたりなんですね
子供には無理だからね
無理し もう暗い世界でしょうに
光と電気もなかった時代でしたからね
でも悔しかったんですね
本当に その時枝落ちるのこれ見たかったなとかね
それでも言いたかっ言いたいところはやっぱり仏教の思考がやっぱり入ってますから
証拠出せっていうぐらいは言うんです
あまり科学的に厳密に考えないんだから
まあいいんじゃないか
そのその程度でいいんじゃないかというふうに落ち着くところもあります
それはあんまり日本ではね
論理は使いませんだからね
今丹波さんが来て じゃあ証拠出せって言えばいいのに
じゃあテレビカメラに映すように
二 三秒でいいんだからとかね
あの連中は何で言わないのかと
言っちゃうと 番組の雰囲気가 壊れるとかね
自分たちはお金で出ている出演しているし
日本人を騙すっていうことははっきりと知っていますから
そんなこと言っちゃうと日本人がもう騙せないでしょうと
騙さなきゃ見てくれないでしょうと
すごいそこそこっぽいですね
まあだからこのそんな感じで霊の話言うならばわかりやすいんだけど
仏教の世界でも霊の話あるんだけど
そう簡単に言わないんです
目連尊者が龍樹禅で餓鬼を見たんだけど
その時見たところで面白くなっちゃって笑っちゃったんです
しかし なんで笑ったのかと言わない
お釈迦様もみんないるところで聞きなさいと
なぜとはっきり書くんですよ
そういうことは証拠なしに言うもんじゃないんだよと
証拠がなく言っちゃうと
人々を何か信仰させたことになります
だから そこで証拠はお釈迦様なんです
証人 証拠というか 場合証拠は難しいんだから
その場合証人 そこで目連尊者がこの餓鬼の説明したんです
こんな感じの餓鬼を見ましたよと
言うと お釈迦様は あ 実は私もその餓鬼を見ました
大体いつ どうして それは全部今
その時ここいうことで言った時はそこら辺でこういうところでしょ
こういうところでこんな感じで見ましたよとかね
それで二人が証人だからね
同じことを霊能者が二人が見るんだから
いくらかマシですよ 日本のテレビではそうじゃないんで
オーラ見える人がいるんですけど
ある人には赤く見える
ある人に紫色に見える
ある人に白く だからあの人のオーラが何ですかね
結局は だからなんでそこまで嘘言って金儲かるんですかね
ある番組見ていたんですけど
みんな超能力者たちが並んできて
オーラなんかは簡単に見えますよと
あなたは見えますよ で
ぐらいはと では何々さんのオーラを見てくださいと
ある一人の人のオーラ見るんです
じゃあどう？ああ そうですね
このなんかピンク色のオーラです
次に ああ やっぱり青い色ですね
やっぱり紫色 だからオーラって何色ですかね？その人
例えばさんのオーラだったら
これ何かあるでしょうに
その時点で言ってることはいい加減嘘っていうことになるでしょうに
だから丹波さんがテレビ番組に死んだのに参加しているのというならば
もう一つの霊能者がもう一つの霊能者も認めたならばね
三人グループ組んで嘘を言ってるなんてことになりますよ
最低それぐらいでもないんですね
ブッダの場合はやっぱりもうそういうことは証人ぐらいでもなければっていうことでね
お釈迦様はなんでその霊がそんなひどい目に遭ったのかという過去物語を言うんですね
昔 ある独覚仏陀な一人で悟った仏陀なんですけど
説法しない仏陀ですね
いた時はこの葉っぱで
で このブッダが独覚仏陀がこのどこかでこの川のところでちょこっと葉っぱで葉っぱを拭いてちょこっとしたハット
まあまあ夜ちょこっと座れる
横になるぐらいの小さなものがあって
作ってもらって そちらに住んでいて
それから村に托鉢に行ってご飯を召し上がって
また説法しませんだからね
独覚仏陀っていうのは
禅定に入っている しかし悟っている方だからね
一般の人々にとっては見るだけでも徳を集めるし
拝んだだけでも徳を集めるし
やっぱり人々はこの聖者を見て挨拶して礼をするためにも行く
その道のところである人が田んぼを作っているんですね
それでいっぱい人々が行くんだから
この田んぼの上であろうがまるっきり気にしない
とにかく行く この人は何をやっているのか
今苦労して田んぼを作っているのに
これ踏まないでくださいと
もう何頑張ってもこの行儀の悪い連中がやっぱり田んぼの上
なんか仏教の連中行儀悪いのは昔から決まってるみたいですけど
で 言うことは聞かない
だから本人にしたらものすごく迷惑でしょうにね
いくらなんでも で 怒ったんです
この聖者がね この田んぼの向こうの川のところでね
こんなもうそこで住んでいるんだから
いつでもみんなもう近い距離でね
もうそちらに行くんだよと
だから私の田んぼは無茶苦茶になるんだよと
これはもうかなわないんだよと
で ブッダが出て行くまで待っていて
托鉢に 火を付けたんです
あのハットに だからこの人はこのあの葉っぱの家をね
燃やしちゃって で ブッダが托鉢終わって来たら
もうそれ燃えてるんだからね
別にどこかへ行ったんです
どこでもいればいいんだからね
それで人々はまた大勢に来て
まだ燃えてるんですね
ちょこちょこと 住んでいたこの小さな家
小屋がね 燃えてるんです
ブッダはどこに行ったのかと
で 探すとこの田んぼを作っている人がもうわざとやりましたからね
もうだからこちらの行儀が悪いしね
信者さんの あのね 私はそれ燃やしましたと
私はそれ燃やしましたと
言うと この人たちはもうあなたのせいで
我々にはもうこれからもうお供えすることもできなくなったと
言って その人を殴っちゃって
もうもう殺しちゃったんですね
殴ったところで もうちょっとやりすぎて死んでしまったんですね
だから行儀悪いっていうことはもうはっきりしていますね
パッキャオブッダも説法もしないんだから
もう戒律一個も教えません
祝福ちょこっとするだけで
それで彼が地獄に落ちちゃって
地獄で罪を償いをして
この残りの臭いだけで悪業のね
本当はもう終わってます
悪業は 終わったんですけど
まあちょこっとまだ微妙に痕残っている
手術の痕みたいに まあ病気は終わったんですけど
やっぱり手術されたっていうところでちょこちょこっと不自由なところ残りますからね
そんな感じでちょこちょこっとまだ業が残っていて
これ餓鬼道に落ちちゃって
あの蛇になっているんだと
そこで蛇になったところで
二五余旬の体で体ずっとあの何か石油の油田が火がついたような感じで終わることなく
体中燃えている で 顔だけは人間の顔で人間の頭で
体は蛇で燃えているんだと
だからなんで体は蛇になったかと
それはもうさっぱり業のことだからもうわかりませんし
とにかく燃えて燃えている
あの餓鬼道って言ったって嘘じゃなくて
そこっていうのはもう成り立ちますよ
なぜならば この物質的に物事を考えちゃうと
一回燃えたら終わりでしょうにと
死ぬでしょうにと思いますけど
あの体っていうのは物質でできた体じゃなくて
自分の心が作る体なんですね
だから心があるんだから体があるんですよ
そこで悪業でこの心が作った体だから
当然ぐちゃぐちゃ燃えたりする
本人にそれ改良できません
例えば我々の今の体も我々の業が作った体ですよ
自分の鼻がちょっと短いのではないかとか思ったってね
これどうしようもないんです
もうちょっと足の方が長く長い方が良かったとかね
そんなこと言ったってもね
一応基本的な私の顔はもうちょっと細く細くて欲しかったとかね
首はもうちょこっと細くて長かった方がいいんだとか
色々あるでしょ 要求は
誰にしたっても だから気持ちはあるんだけど
体はそう変わりません
今の体は自分の業がずっと作っているんです
だから微妙にでも変えたければ
この思考をずっと変えなく変えなくちゃいけないです
思考をすっごく変えて
ものすごく明るい思考で清らかな思考でいると
体の悪い欠点というのは完璧には消えませんけど
まあ問題にならないようになっちゃうんですね
いわゆるあまり気付かないとかね
他の人 あんたちょっと首が短すぎて
ちょっとなんか何だこのちょっと気持ち悪い時もそれがなくなっちゃうんですね
これでこれでいいやという風に周りも思うようにはプロポーションが一応整えてはきます
だから日本の方々はとにかくアメリカ人とまるっきり同じようになりたいと期待しているんですけど
いくらいくらもう心清らかに修行したってもなりませんと思いますけどね
まあヨーロッパ人と同じくちょこっと迫力のある体形には変わるかもしれません
ちょっと迫力ある体にはもう変わるかもしれません
そういうわけで この我々の体さえも業が作っているんです
基本のセットは 骨組みは
だから私たちの便利なところは
体心 業が作るのが基本的なセットで
この上にいっぱい物質を叩いて叩いて自分で作るんですね
だからご飯食べたり おっぱい飲んだり
いろんなことをして物質を入れるんです
物質を入れてみても 基本の骨組みの上に体が作るんです
そういうことだから 簡単に壊れます
我々の体は 外から取った物質だから
それはもう燃やしちゃうと燃えてしまいます
で 餓鬼道の場合は業だけ体作るんです
だから当然我々には見えません
見えるところまでごっつい硬い濃いもう質の質量がものすごい体ではないんです
しかしそれが本人に燃えてしまうんですよ
燃えても燃えても体がそのままあるんです
寿命尽きるまでは死にません
だから人間の思考で一回燃えたらそれで終わります
それは人間ですよ 人間の体は一回燃えたらそれで終わりますけど
餓鬼はそうならないんですね
まあ本当に餓鬼はそんな形かということはわかりませんだけど
まあ人間にストーリー語ってますから
人間にイメージできるように
頭でイメージできるように語ってます
まあだからそんな程度でよろしいんじゃないかなと
だから我々はイメージできるでしょうにね
すごいなんかもうヘクトくらい長い体だったら
太さも相当でしょうしね
それにつける首はどれぐらいでしょうかね
そこをまたゴーゴーと燃えているとすればね
そういうふうに なんで体を大きくイメージさせるのかというと
身動きできないということ
そうすると苦しみはなおさらきついんですよ
身動きできない だから蛇になったでしょうね
体は もし餓鬼の体は鳥のように翼がついていたならば
飛んで行ってどこかで何とかというもう可能ですけど
そういう自由はないんです
だいたい餓鬼の霊っていうのはほとんど身動きができないんです
どんな餓鬼でも一箇所にカチッと止めている
それすごい苦しいんです
[背景音楽]神々も霊なんですけど
彼らはすごい幸福で楽しく生きているし
一箇所に止めるということはないんです
自由に動ける 餓鬼も霊なんです
餓鬼は動けません 固定します
だから苦しんでる羽目になります
とにかく心で いわゆるこう考えれば
自分の頭が幻想を作っているんだと
それぐらいだったら人間にも経験があるでしょうに
特にこのすごい高熱になった時はいっぱい幻覚見るでしょ
その時は本物ですよ 高熱で
あるいは薬でも使ったりして
いろんな夢見たり幻覚を見たりするときは
この本人にとっては大変です
本物です で 例えば病気になったところで
何か恐ろしい幻覚を見えたと
何か周りからいろんな人が来て
自分をもうクタクタでいろんな刃物で刺したんだと
刺しているんだと言うと
本当に本人は刃物で刺しているような苦しみと恐怖感は感じます
私たちにはまあまあそれ病気だから気にしないでくださいと言ったってもね
本人にとってはもうそんな遊びで済むものじゃないんです
だから心は怖いんですよ
だから餓鬼道というのは
地獄っていうのはそうやって純粋に幻覚だけで生きている次元だと思っておけばあまり議論になりません
純粋に幻覚だけの世界
心があって幻覚を作って
幻覚の中で入り込んでいる
心は自由がないんだから
我々にしたって心わかることで
自分の好きなように体は変わってくれませんし
好きなことはいっぱいあるんだけど
うまくはいきませんだからね
体力はこれぐらいあった方がいいやとかね
能力はこれぐらい向上した方がいいやとかね
今日一日中この本を読んでレポート書こうとかね
できればありがたいんだけど
やっぱりそうはうまくいかないんですよ
やっぱり能力次第だからね
だから心の欲はいっぱいあったっても
心は業の能力以外は発揮しません
だからリミットされています
だから地獄餓鬼道の生命にも
そういうリミットが当然確実に付いています
人間にはリミットはいくらか自由ですよ
神々にもリミットはあるんです
神々は広辞苑かもしれませんだけど
彼らも心だけで生きているんだから
心だけが作る幻想世界で
だからリミットが成り立つのです
人間だけありがたいことに物質に依存するんですよ
だから物質をいじれます
欲望で やっぱりもう肌はね
気持ち悪い色であっても塗ればいいんです
何か 美しく見えます みずみずしい肌とか何とか願ってるでしょう
油系の何か塗っておけば
もう体のね 水分が出ていかないし
それでもうみずみずしい顔になりますよ
そのチャンスは人間にあります
髪の毛がもうほとんど落ちて薄くなって
すっごいかっこ悪いと
カツラ着ければね バレないようにと
それでかっこよく見えたりする
だからそれは物質に依存しているんだから
その辺でもうなんとか
自分の気持ちをね 本物じゃない
本物になることはできませんだけど
なんとなく自分の希望や気持ちをちょこっと一時的にでも何か実現したのごとく遊んだりすることはできます
だからそこは霊にはできませんし
地獄の生命にできませんし
神々にさえできません
決まってるプログラムで動くしかないんです
人間の便利なところ そういうところ
まあそういうことだから
人間には工夫できる できて心を育てたり
いろいろできるということで
人間の次元だけは無駄にするなよと
天国に生まれたら もしかするとね
1万年とかね 軽々く 一番下の天国っていうのは 1日100年でしたっけ？100年ぐらい 100
年  100年あたりでしょう
一番下の天国は  1日100年で
人間の時間でいえば それで 3回が 1年
で もう100年ぐらい寿命があるんだと言ったら
相当時間でしょ で 人間の寿命といえばね
百年というだけで実際は短いしね
だから ものすごく残念に思うほど命は短いんです
生命の それは無駄にしてはいけません
ゴルフやる暇があったらもっと生産的なことをやればいいと思いますけどね
無駄話する 無駄話して精神病気になるでしょ
これはもう無駄とも言わないんです
ゴルフはいくらか無駄や無駄でもまあしょうがないと許すということできますよ
だって楽しんでるんだからね
それなりにいろいろバカなことやって腕上がったりもするんだから
まあしょうがないって大目に見ることできますよ
でも人間無駄話したりすることは
あれはもう明確に罪ですよ
時間もなくなるだけじゃなくて
性格まで悪くなるでしょうに
それから無駄話って妄想の一種でしょうに
それで精神的にもイカれちゃうでしょうに
やってはいけないんです
だから我々はすごい時間を大事にしないといけないということにはなります
時間は短い それで なのに人間が平気で悪のみしないという生き方をしているのはなぜかというと
やっぱりそれがやりやすくて
すぐ結果見えませんだからね
結果があるということは見えないと
ただそれだけのことでやられています
話は以上です はい えーと
回り一応  今悪のみしないとおっしゃったんですか？悪のみする
うん あ そうですね 悪のみを他しないということで
[笑い]